yes you're now live chair
right well we'll begin now um
good evening fellow councillors and uh
welcome to
ladies and gentlemen who are joining us
on youtube to the full council meeting
of torres district council
2nd november 2020.
uh we've just had prayers by reverend
john ward
much appreciated i would just like to
say before we begin i will be
laying a wreath on behalf of torridge on
on sunday at the war memorial in
biddeford
although of course there won't be any
formal um
parade or meeting as such it'll just be
turning up
at the appointed hour to observe them in
silence and to
lay the wreath so we'll start then with
um the register i think and then we'll
deal with um
um absences so who's doing the register
his test teacher thank you kirstie
okay councillor yeah here
councillor brenton president cancer
bright
yeah mr brown
present that's the bushby president
councillor ford
he is here here story here
council look up
hmm
[Music]
harding
that's the harding
that's the hawkins yeah
there seems to be a lot of interference
from your reading kirsty i don't know if
anybody else can hear it
yeah all right sorry councillor james
thank you councillor langford present
laws
[Music]
present thank you i'll just say i didn't
hear my name read out counts a lot
i think it's the crackling chair is mary
are you there sorry before we carry on
is it no better from me oh it's not i
don't know if mary wants to carry on
taking the votes going forward
tom i'm here can you hear me yeah that's
yeah are you okay to do the
no it's all good it must be cursed are
you right to do them going forward
yep absolutely thank you i didn't hear
councillor rossi
being called either he's apologies too
okay fair enough
uh councillor dub councillor cop signing
in please
all right thank you and chancellor laws
please
very sorry okay so you should be
you know detention for you um well uh
the apologies now then please
jail we have apologies from councillor
rossi council of art and councillor
hutchings
thank you very much so now we're going
to item two which is the council minutes
and they're from pages four to twenty
three i should go through the page by
page
which is 4 5 6
7 8 9
10 11
12 13
14 15
16 17 yeah
which which item item number 17 there
please the
all right yeah i i see yes okay uh
counselor golf here um
just an update please have written those
in motion about the retractable cover
victoria uh swimming pool there
yes that's really important um which
committee is it going on so is it major
project
works or when is it going on there and
just a reason why hasn't gone to
community resources because it's finance
i mean it was
it was going to major projects but
they've they've not met yet have they
i don't think am i right just change
that's correct
um sorry go miss
uh chair yeah that's correct the major
property major projects working group
meeting hasn't been held yet we are in
the process of setting up
that meeting to review the capital
program
and this being a capital program will go
forward
as part of the work for that meeting
which would then go on to
community resources committee for any
decision making
thank you okay 18
yes i have my hand up for number page
9 i think it is is it um
strategic plan um
have i missed something or when is when
is the meeting to review the
um strategic plan going to take place
please
steve could you answer that a minute
please i i can't um
i'm trying to find the page a minute um
chair so we've had the meeting to adopt
the plan so that
is now the council's strategic plan
there are a number of items
returned through the consultation
process if that's what
councillor haims is referring to um then
we're doing putting the work together to
identify those items and we'll bring
them back which will probably be at the
next
call council meeting in december thank
you right
okay okay so we're now
on page 18 19.
20 21
22 23.
so uh would somebody move those minutes
as a true record
chair castle hackett
yeah so now we go to the vote for them
to be approved
so we start again please kirsty
mary oh sorry mary yeah thank you record
yes charm eddie council about him
four
councillor brenton or
santa bright
council christie
he's not with us mary okay
council o'clock four
abstain
foreign
four
councillor
councillor lanford
excuse me hello excuse me
mckenzie still not present
councilman thank you
councillor newton four
councillor pennington huntington
four thank you council watson
thank you thank you councillors
we moved to item four then declarations
of interest
you know what the rules are that you
should declare them at the appropriate
time
when the item comes up on the agenda
describe the nature of your interest
sorry hello
item three or four sir sorry
oh i've been working through your item
no no i've
i've rushed ahead with my pencil i'm
sorry public contributions number three
we have one speaker
mr mr smith i understand good evening
ladies and gentlemen
good evening um as you know i am
not able to speak completely for the
full time myself because of
to say what so i asked my
son-in-law just to read out my volunteer
statement to you
i thought it to most of you you should
have received it so you know what it
says
but uh i will have to pass this over to
chris murdock my son-in-law
because i'm not capable of reading it
are you happy with that
yes that's fine thank you hi chris can
you
well good evening everyone this is a
statement by uh
alan smith uh today second of november
uh six years ago torrid sold to my
company the land formerly known as the
british square
in westwood subject to a covenant not to
develop other than
the purchase price was agreed with the
district valuer and the sale approved by
cnr committee and full council
planning application was made in exactly
the same form as agreed
in the contract despite officer
recommendations approved
now unanimously refused by the plans
committee
on the grounds the land was public open
space
this gave the public false information
that has remained with them as some
cancers ever since
a second application was submitted in
the same form
against officer recommendation this time
the plans committee
unanimously refused on grounds of hotel
size not suitable
for the site both planning applications
were granted on appeal
in 2017. during the purchase procedure
it became
obvious that nearly all the councillors
and a large number of residents
were against the hotel being built on
this site
i'm obliged to build a hotel as in the
contract with tdc
many residents and council members
expressed concern that the sale of the
land was not legal
and there was collusion between officers
and myself
this opinion is still evident amongst
some members
councillor hodson was elected on her
stop the hotel banner
and her husband publicly suggested that
tdc be challenged on their action to
obtain best price
as council laws has done she should
declare a prejudicial
interest and take no part in this
meeting or any other discussions
concerning this site
because of ill health i will never be
able to complete the latter 51 project
i asked members to decide what would be
best for westwood home
the specification for a hotel as
required by tvc
will put off any other developer showing
an interest
by amending the covenant other other
developers will be able to put forward
fresh ideas to be agreed with tdc by the
proper planning committee
and cnr if increase in value is
applicable
the current use of the land has been
well received by the public and tourists
we will continue this code compliant use
and make substantial capital
improvements subject to torridge
not taking action to stop this use
through the existing covenant
this is a very important site that will
remain the center of westeros for
generations to come
if you don't like the new beer garden we
will consider any sensible financial and
economic alternative ideas for this site
remember this site is only 16 meters by
22 meters
the building now with detailed planning
just fits on
the on-site car parking is not included
in the subject land
i have sent a copy of covenant to all
members for them to understand
the conditions this mess has come about
because the major committees in the
council do not work together
and also there is an underlying bad
feeling between the developer and
several members
cdc did not have to sell the land they
could have taken the leases back
and made it a public village square tdc
had already designated an alternative
site for the village square activities
the question is what does torrey want to
do with this site
thank you thank you very much
uh alan i hope you uh get well
or at least keep out of pain as much as
humanly possible
so
right hold up okay then thank you very
much for a contribution
as you know it's coming up on the agenda
later on yeah
all right good night no we stay here
i'm going yet yep
so now we come to well we've already
done declarations of interest
now we come to item five agreements
gender part one and two there are um
uh two items in part two we need to take
a vote on that
so mary when you're ready
yep cancel about him you need to
change the proposal yeah
i propose part two okay
thank you thank you very much okay so
now it goes to the vote
council about him for
councillor brandon four time
[Music]
or cancer ford
or councillor cup
for councillor hackett
or councillor haynes
or councillor hawkins
or councillor
for council hex
for councillor hudson
council hurley uh sure chair my screen
froze so i don't know what
we're voting actually for the covenant
to be removed are we
no we're voting on
part two oh sorry okay yeah four
thank you councillor inch
f4 councillor james
four councillor jones
four councillor langford
or councillor manly
or councillor newton
or councillor pennington
county
councillor watson four
thank you councilor wiseman oh
thank you care unanimous thank you
mary yes um thank you very much
councillors now we move to item
six uh now steve
harris has got some update now on the
latest government
uh regulations vis-a-vis covid and how
it will affect us on torridge
steve you want to proceed on yes thanks
chair so just uh just a brief update i
guess so
i'm sure members will have been
following a lot of the information
that's been coming out
since the prime minister addressed the
nation on
saturday evening so yesterday afternoon
the leader and i joined a call with
robert generick the secretary of state
for mhclg where he
outlines a bit more information about
the the roles and responsibilities of
local authorities uh that will be
expected of us over the next
four weeks some of that information has
been coming out during
the course of the day and some further
information
is expected over the course of the next
couple of days
um it's clear from from what we've been
told and what we see it'll be somewhat
different
to the first lockdown that started uh
back in march in so far as
a lot of different sectors and settings
will still be able to operate as we've
seen schools colleges universities
etc will still be operational
as will things like the housing market
construction
manufacturing some of those trades
industries like electricians plumbers
builders etc will still
will still be operational obviously
there's a
an expectation that public services will
still operate
and so in terms of tourist district
council services
uh we'll still be running i won't say as
per
normal but as per normal as much as we
can given
uh the extent of the the restrictions
um there'll be a lot of expectations of
us
to put in additional measures and
support which i'll come on to
obviously one of the the critical areas
i think
that will close and specific i guess to
this area is around hospitality um and
clearly we have a significant element of
torridge
involved in the hospitality sector the
other things that
will remain open to things like outdoor
playgrounds play areas and
and so forth so as i said we're
expecting a lot more information to come
come forward we've just just received as
we've been on online
information about the critical
extremely vulnerable and that shielding
framework
so i've just forwarded that to members
of the team
and the expectation is that will be in
place by
thursday fundings just being made
available
and although that will go to devon
county and not to
the lower tier district councils and
there's letters going out to
all those individuals who were on the
shielding list
last time albeit shielding will not be
um in place as it was uh the case the
first time around
and just a greater expectation that
those
who would ordinarily shield will not be
going to work
where they can work from home and things
like will not go to shops if they can
avoid
doing so and minimizing contact with
other
individuals but we'll we'll get some
more information out
as and when we've digested what's just
been released
um in terms of uh financial support i'm
sure you will have seen
the furlough scheme going to continue
for for the next month
mortgage holiday support to be extended
as well
um so on the more pressing issues for
torridge and the things that we have to
put in place for our
businesses in terms of financial support
there's a support package for those
businesses that have to close during
this four week period
and grants that will be available for
this period
um dependent on rateable value
but up to a maximum of 3 000
pounds per premises for this period
there's also an announcement of a
further 1.1
billion pound nationally um to put in
place
um a discretionary business
hardship fund um that's similar to the
the sums of money that were being put in
place
to those authorities uh predominantly up
north
where they were going into tier three
restrictions
under the the previous scheme so we
understand
it's 20 pounds uh per
taxpayer per capita um so we expect that
to be somewhere in the region of 1.2
million for torridge
um so we're already underway in terms of
putting together that discretionary
business support scheme and we'll get
information
out as soon as as possible on both of
those schemes
but obviously you'd ask that business
business owners bear with us as we get
that information out but we'll release
some
uh public and media information very
shortly
um there's also some additional uh
financial support
for local authorities in terms of
contact tracing facilities
and for enforcement measures clearly
they'll be
different levels of enforcement
to these restrictions as as against what
was in place
previously and again we waited for
information
to come out from government government
that will help us put those
schemes in place um so as i said we want
we shouldn't see
any significant changes to the way the
council operates
although because the the message has
changed in terms of
stay at home where you can't
work in your from home
so a larger number of our staff
will be working from home uh and be
doing so
over the next course of the next couple
of days we will however keep our
reception area open
because we're aware um particularly in
this this period
cold weather etc that you know there are
some very vulnerable people out there so
we need to keep
services available at our reception
areas
should there be a need for customers to
come in
so as i said we expected most public
services to be
back still in place to things like
recycling centers
although they're operated by the county
council the indication is
that they should still operate as normal
chair that's all i've got to update at
present but
as we get more information we'll release
it both to counsellors
and to our residents through our
press releases and through our media
releases
thanks chair thank you steve that's um
that's very comprehensive so it will be
of sort of rolling uh
information coming to you as things
progress
councilor pennington's raised his hand
all right okay answer pennington
thank you chair um on saturday the
national announcement the chief medical
officer said
the southwest um although the lowest
area in the country in torridge
particularly
we are vulnerable because of a different
funding of the nhs
and i hope this council will ask the
question
what is the funding arrangement so
different in the southwest compared to
other areas of the country
um and can they be corrected so that at
least if we are in a low vulnerable
area like cornwall and ourselves our
business
aren't so effective if it's not
necessary but the key issue i wanted to
raise
we should be asking why is the southwest
hospitals on a different funding
as was said by the chief medical officer
on saturday at the full government
announcement
thank you chair thank you councillor
penton i'm sure
steve first will uh get the answer to
that question
i'd like to know that much sorry sorry
sorry
thanks yes i obviously don't know the
answer to that question directly
although one thing we do know is that
the the number
or the bed capacity in the southwest is
lower than that
in other areas of the country and us
having
a greater population in the older
generation obviously that puts
a different perspective in terms of the
incidence of
infection in this area um but yeah i
don't know the
the funding formula for nhs hospitals um
i'm sure we're gonna attempt to find out
thank you thank you
right now we go to item seven
we don't have any questions under
procedural rule
a9 so then is item eight
covenant hotel site westward ho got a
report in front of you
well we've got history really of what's
been going on from page 24 to 41
chair councillor james and council laws
have raised their hand
right well well i've got to declare an
interest
okay councillor hicks noted
councillor brenton claire hodson can i
make a statement please
it's important i do i think i wish to
declare an interest
um and uh um i won't take part
thank you uh but councillor james was
first
to to speak actually sorry this is with
regard to interest
oh sorry chancellor brenton the
interesting interesting that's
just well i'd like to make the following
personal statement if it's possible
please
uh regarding the public contribution
that you've heard tonight
i have no intention or need
to declare an interest in the agenda
item regarding the covenant on the hotel
site
i did not campaign under a stop
the hotel banner as i've stated before
my canvassing literature is readily
available
to anybody who wants to see it i was
elected to represent westwood ho to the
best of my ability
and to serve the interests of the people
of torridge
and this remains my sole objective
so i will not be declaring an interest
thank you okay thank you councillor
um councillor james
right thank you chair if i i would like
to defer this item um as you know
under our constitution we need to refer
any ons decision to the next full
council
which we have done unfortunately
the um the recommendation from ons
that we've been asked to vote on it's
not fully explained
and i think we need to defer into got
more information
as you can hear this is obviously
slightly controversial
so i would like us to move it that we
defer
and we bring forward a full report on
the options
so we can make a solid decision that
it doesn't keep going backwards and
forwards so that is my
recommendation that we defer from this
meeting do you have a secretary for that
sorry castle watson so cancer what
you're seconding
yeah okay right well we've had this this
has been an ongoing thing you've had a
lot of paperwork in front of you about
this
over the time so i'm going to go
straight to the vote on this because if
we're having a further report
we don't need to debate this now we'll
wait till we got more information
so we'll um
mary we're going to the vote
council brown or
cantona bushby or
cancer christie oh
cattle clark oh
council hawkins
yeah four four thank you
councillor apple
council hex
or council inch
four council of james
or councillor jones
against
councillor lazard four
councillor
he's left the meeting yep sorry thank
you
tell the lever or
foreign
could i say that i'm for as well and
apologize for my lateness to the meeting
i was uh stuck in the work commitment
all right thank you very much okay thank
you
yeah that's 27 for one against and one
abstention
thank you mary thank you okay you've got
councillor ford's hand up
oh right i thought that was miss prince
okay councillor four we we've taken the
vote now cancer ford
is it a point of order
cancer ford hello yo
hello yes it was a point of order
well it's just carrying on very briefly
that i take on board the uh
public uh speaker and what you sell on
about
interest is what and what's overstated
before we have taken the vote
that's fine i'll discuss it next time
yes right that's right yeah
right after days that's no problem okay
so now item nine great torrential
neighborhood plan is a hundred pages
there of uh
their uh neighborhood plan it follows
the set this will follow the same
pattern as we did for weekly last time
whereby we uh
note it and um i think we have to take a
vote on it don't we stacy
just uh but we don't have any input into
it
okay you've got dawn burgess yeah who's
gonna present it
oh is she okay all right
dawn
okay hello she's just trying to unmute
can you hear me i can indeed
right i'll come into the presentation if
you're happy with that
could could the speaker introduce
yourself please sorry i'm
sorry i'm don burgess i'm one of the
senior planning policy officers and i've
been working with the community on
this project for some time thank you
and the purpose of this item is for the
council to agree the report of an
examiner on the great toilet
neighbourhood plan
to agree the proposed modifications
which are set out in the decision
statement
and the reasons for them and to agree
that the revised neighbourhood plan
should progress to a referendum
and as said that set out in the report
this could not be undertaken before
the 6th of may 2011.
so the port sets out progression of the
great toronto neighborhood planned from
the designation of a neighborhood area
in 2014
to the assessment by an independent
examiner in 2019
the delay in bringing the report to this
council results from
the consequence of the first covalent
hello hello hello
um and to ensure the town council were
able to consider and accept the
examiner's
recommendations and post modifications
to the neighborhood plan
your offices have worked with the town
council and then as members will see
from report
the town council are supportive proposed
modifications and progression of the
neighborhood
plan to a referendum the examiner
determined that subject to several
changes the neighborhood plan could meet
all necessary requirements
and therefore subject to the agreement
of this council it can progress to
referendum
all significant changes to the
neighborhood plan are set out in the
decision statement which is appendix 2
to the support
which together with minor corrections
are presented in
the proposed draft referendum version
which is appendix 3 of the report
your officers recommend that the
modifications resulted from the
examiner's report are accepted
and as soon as practical to do so a
referendum could be held
if members agree the recommendations
within the support the policies
contained within the neighborhood plan
will be significant in decision making
in relevant planning applications
where relevant to tollington
the timing of the publication of
decision statement will be discussed
with the town council
so i would expect that to be within the
next few weeks thank you chair
thank you dawn so now then we
can move to the vote to approve that
okay councillor bushby's raised his hand
all right council bush b
sorry the reason i was uh asked the
speaker to introduce yourself
it says this is the report of the
planning and
econo
yes but he hasn't been dealing with this
report
well that's that was my query it says
it says on the screen to receive the
report of the planning and economy
manager
and i didn't know who i haven't met the
lady that was speaking so
i was a bit confused as to you know
right who was presenting what
okay all right
right so we need to go to the vote on
this so um
proposal in the chair that we approve
and
a second chair thank you council watson
so mary william go vote again
okay cancel about him uh four
council brandon or cancer bright
school
abstain
answer christie
answer christy
thank you council clark
councillor cottle hankin
councillor craigie or
councillor ford uh four and i'll be
leaving a meeting because i've been up
since i have three
good evening all thank you
thank you councillor cup four
councillor hackett
four four can you hear me
yeah thank you thank you council haines
oh chancellor hawkins
oh thank you council apple
four councillor james
[Music]
councillor jones
four
[Music]
[Music]
captain mcgough or
councillor mckenzie
four councillor manly
or councillor newton
or councillor pennington
or councillor watson
or councillor wiseman
oh thank you
yeah that's 31 4 and 1 abstention
item 10 northern destination management
organization a nice mouthful
well you've got a report on pages one
four three two one
four nine and uh we've got an officer
who's going to address it
thank you chair it's uh sean here the
planning economy manager for those who
don't know me
are you sure yeah i'm fairly certain
aren't you
um so chair the the report you've got in
front of you is is all about
north devon plus his efforts to assist
us in the
covert recovery plan um they've been
looking at the
options around setting up a destination
management organization and the attached
paper talks a little bit about tourism
and it's important to the local economy
it talks about dmos
and what they do and the opportunities
they present it also goes through the
need
to do something the industry's been hit
so hard and sets out the proposal
what we're talking about here tonight is
not about whether we should it's about
whether we should investigate setting up
a dmo
and we're seeking your endorsement for
that because it's really important to
get that from the outset
and the fact that we would look for some
funding so over to you chair
thank you very much sean well as you can
see from the report councillors
um this really really would mean us
just getting involved with this to see
what we can extract
for our authority and it's interesting
to note on page 149
on the third bullet point down that
there
are uh eight recognized dmos in devon
uh ranging from dart more directs more
but none
focusing on northern devon so it's i
think it's very important that we
uh take part in this it's as it's just
exploration at this stage there's no
money attached to it
uh or anything at this moment but at
least the decision then
on page requested rather on page 149 and
i'll move it from the chair
to agree in principle to explore the
opportunities
that this will bring us a secretary i'll
second that
claire thank you cancer holston
hi everybody you've got accounts you've
got councillor manly and councillor
hackett's hands raised
it's okay i was just going to
do what david's done then i was going to
do what claire's done but they've both
done it
i'm going back to being quiet don't do
that
and and i finished fourth in this race
as well so i was going to do the same so
i sure
i should not go any further thank you
thank you chair
well i think okay you've now got sorry
sorry sorry you've got councillor
leather and councillor lock hands raised
now
okay cancel another person thank you
chair well i think the recommendations
are actually the ones on what page 144
there's two of them there five point one
and five point two and i
i was going to remove both those
recommendations chair
first thing same difference okay fair
enough
council lock chair yeah i was just going
to say
bottom of the last paragraph on page 143
um there will be trying to secure
external funds at this time there is no
request of financial assistance from the
council
but i'm sure at some stage if this
project takes off
we will be asked to put some money in
but i still think it's a
good thing to join and support
definitely
right okay so um
take your pick i'll move from the chair
on the on six but
uh councillor leather uh has referred us
to the sort of um
the actual recommendation put on five
same difference actually but never mind
or
we'll go with counsellor shall we and um
his moving of the recommendations on
page one four four and we'll have a
second oh well our second
second okay so the second is propose a
second
and we'll move to the vote thank you
council about him at four
councillor brenton or councillor bright
or councillor brown
four councillor bushby
or
oh cantaloupe
for councillor hackett or
council haynes or
councillor hawkins for
cancer
thor councillor james
or councillor jones
or councillor langford
or councillor laws
all
oh
mackenzie four
councillor manly or
councillor newton yes
councillor pennington
thank you mary so we moved to item 11
then
cycle committee meetings well we've got
something to look forward to in 2021
so uh here you go i think um steve
you've got something to say on this
um chair not a lot obviously it's
attached as uh appendix one to your
report
although i just just noted on the
appendix one there's a
um an indication against the 20th of
september
next year that i also have something to
look forward to
but that shouldn't distract from uh
holding a full council meeting
so or perhaps you know something we
don't then
if you think you're going to plan a
holiday in september next year
i'd like to uh i'd like to think you're
up right
in fact if it's that good i should
probably be on holiday myself so there
you go
um and then we'll take the vote on this
unless anybody's got something
to amend nope sorry
councillor haines yes i just want if it
would be useful to send um
the cycle of meetings out to parish
council so they know
what we're doing so that they don't
clash with their meetings
oh well that is that is optimism
counselor aims
never mind well we're trying to try and
do that at northern church
yeah well we um we i believe we do send
them out to uh
oh god yes is that right tim
steve hurst i'm sure we do because i
know biddeford used to get them
i think i think that's the case chair
yeah if it isn't we certainly will
again i think they do get them all right
well go to the vote then um
i'll move forward in seconds please sure
well i'm proposing and and i'll i'll
second that chair
tony h so now we'll vote
until about him uh four
brenton or shelter bright
or councillor brown
or councillor bushby
or council christie
council clark oh councillor cottle
hunting
oh council craigie oh
cancel a cup for council hackett
for councillor haines or
councillor harting sorry
councillor hawkins or
counselor happily or
chancellor hicks or
council hudson or kepler
or cancer inch
four councillor james
or councillor jones
or councillor langford
or councillor laws
or
[Music]
mckenzie four
councillor manly or
councillor newton four
councillor pennington
councillor watson
councillor wiseman oh
yeah that's unanimous thank you very
much mary
so next item is 12. uh
notices of motion we don't have any
tonight uh
13 sorry somebody saying something no
uh 13 petitions we don't have any
petitions
so now i'll move from the chair that we
go into
part two i'll second that counts to lock
thank you very much it's for the to deal
with major projects update
uh which is verbal and uh confirmation
of chief officers
posts which is obviously sensitive
so uh we need to take a vote on this
yes can we have a proposal in a second
so please check
well i propose from the chair i have and
uh councillor lock seconded
brown four chancellor bushby
or council christie
councillor christie left the meeting
okay thank you council clark
councillor carter who
canceled craigie or
councillor gap
for councillor hex
for council hudson
or employee
or councillor inch
or james
or councillor jones
or councillor lanford
yeah four councillor laws
or
mckenzie four
councillor manly or
councillor newton or
councillor pennington
councillor watson or councillor wiseman
oh
thank you very much now we're into part
two
and the first item is chair sorry can i
just leave youtube for a second
ah right yes well thank you very much
members of public who are